en la denominada calle de las brujas de
la paz sobrevive el saber ancestral de
los indígenas de bolivia
margarita quispe es una chamán aymara
que promueve el uso de las hierbas
nativas para infecciones respiratorias y
como antisépticos naturales y
antiinflamatorios con la pandemia adapto
su negocio a la demanda causada por el
coronavirus eucalipto
los dos el neumático que previene el
pulmón
elvira que lo preparamos purple y que
previene y lo pasa con un poco suave no
más no muy fuerte pero ya lo previene
ya sea por la antigua tradición de
tratamientos con plantas o por la
escasez de medicamentos en la epidemia
la población boliviana recurre con mucha
frecuencia a las hierbas medicinales el
estado fomenta ese reconocimiento pero
ha advertido que no son una solución
eficaz para el mal de la pandemia
estamos impulsando lo que es plantas
medicinales pero para infecciones
respiratorias
no podemos confirmar esto es para cobit
directamente si tenemos testimonios muy
buenos que han sido muy bien utilizados
pero no tenemos no estamos confirmando
que es para el comino los médicos
reconocen que el uso de los remedios
caseros está extendido en bolivia pero
recuerdan que el mundo sigue sin una
cura para el cob y 19 efectivamente no
hay una cura para el coronavirus ni ni
por parte farmacológica ni por parte de
piscina tradicional porque no es un
virus no tiene un tratamiento específico
las autoridades han difundido las
propiedades expectorantes y
desinflamantes de las hierbas sin
embargo han insistido en la importancia
de la higiene el uso del barbijo y el
distanciamiento social durante la
pandemia